[Music]
on april 19th
1995 macarthur wheeler robbed a bank
with his face glazed with lemon juice
believing the juice would make his face
invisible to the surveillance cameras he
thought so because lemon juice works as
invisible ink on a piece of paper
police broadcasted the security camera
footage on the local 11 o'clock news
and just after midnight arthur was
arrested
incredulously he said but i wore the
juice
baffled by this reasoning david dunning
and justin kruger
two psychologists studied mr wheeler and
others like him
they came to the conclusion that people
with low ability at a task
tend to paradoxically overestimate
themselves
this cognitive bias is known as the
dunning-kruger effect
let's look at this graphically plotting
one's confidence in your ability
against one's actual knowledge in a
field as we learn something new we are
often highly confident because we know
so little that as soon as we know a tiny
bit
we think we know it all those who stop
learning here
maintain a false sense of mastery those
who continue learning
realize things are more complex and
often lose motivation
and the more they increase their
knowledge the lower their confidence
becomes
many stop at this stage thinking they've
learned nothing
only if we keep going can we regain
confidence while getting better
and at the end we will be full of
knowledge and
almost as confident in our ability as
right after we started
in other words if a simpleton a good
student and a wise teacher were to have
a public debate
this is how things could go down the
simpleton knows just a little bit but is
very confident and voices his opinions
loud and without hesitations
the student knows more but doesn't
realize it because she lacks confidence
she keeps quiet the teacher is confident
but understands how complex things
really are
hence voices his opinions with
reservations
in the end the simpleton wins the
popular vote because he is so confident
about being right
and people tend to trust certainty
research from north america europe and
japan suggests that culture plays a big
role
from assessments of one's own ability to
drive we know that 93
of americans think they are better
drivers than average while only 69
of swedish think so in japan on the
other hand
people in general tend to underestimate
their abilities
as a strategy to see their
underachievement as an opportunity to
improve
setting out on a journey of learning can
be a daunting experience
what starts off as a leisurely stroll
soon changes into an intense battle of
willpower between
you and an intimidating amount of
knowledge do not give up
the longer you fight the more power you
gain
up until the point you win and in the
end
if you persevere you may be elevated to
the ranks of socrates
who over 2 000 years ago left us with a
quote of wisdom
i know that i am intelligent because i
know that i know
[Music]
nothing
sprouts videos are published under the
creative commons license
that means our videos are free and
anyone can download
edit and play them for personal use and
public schools
governments and non-profit organizations
can also use them for training
online courses or designing new
curriculums
to help us stay independent and support
our work you can join our patrons and
contribute
just visit patreon.com sprouts even one
dollar can make a difference
you